a common criticism liberals or
particularly progressives often livia
conservatives is the absence of
compassion so to speak in the formation
of our policies especially under Trump
so what is your position on if
compassion over logic perhaps so I mean
that's what you find a point on empathy
is dumb the reason I say this is not
because I don't have empathy for people
it's because you should not make policy
based on who you care most about if I
did I would take all of your money and
give it to my kids I like them better
than I like you right the fact the fact
is that I mean there's an entire book on
empathy that specifically about why
empathy and policy is a problem sympathy
is fine but having sympathy for people
is good having empathy for people is not
great the distinction being if you have
sympathy you feel bad for someone if you
have empathy you put yourself in the
shoes of that person but by doing so you
are now not in the shoes of everybody
else the best policy that can be made is
the policy that is about you know the
the data and a number of people who are
affected because you can always find the
person who's the most victimized and
then make policy around that person as
opposed to trying to create policy that
affects the most people in the most
beneficial ways so I mean it's great to
be empathetic I don't see empathy as
much as as a moral value as some other
people do I don't think feelings are end
of themselves moral values I think
behavior is moral much more than
feelings maybe this is my Judaic
background but but Judaism is much more
an acts based religion than a grace
based religion meaning that in in our in
my religious viewpoint I think that God
cares much more about what you do then
how you feel about it I think
politically speaking some of the worst
things that ever happened we're based on
good intentions and so you know trying
to formulate policy that is that is the
best without violating people's rights
is a better way of doing policy than
saying I empathize with this group of
people or this particular person and
therefore I'm in a shift policy to meet
them there